we're going to learn to recognize and
factor perfect square polynomials in
this video so for example to have the
polynomial x squared plus 6x plus 9 and
if someone asks you hey can you factor
this into two binomials well using
techniques we learn in other videos okay
I need to find two numbers whose product
is 9 and whose sum is 6 so I encourage
you to think of to pause this video and
say well what two numbers can I can add
up to 6 and if I take the product I get
9
well 9 only has so many factors really 1
3 & 9 & 1 plus 9 does not equal 6 and so
and negative 1 plus negative 9 does not
equal 6 but 3 times 3 equals 9 and 3
plus 3 does equal 6 3 times 3 3 plus 3
and so we can factor this as X plus 3
times X plus 3 which is of course the
same thing as X plus 3 squared and so
what was it about this expression that
made us recognize or maybe now we will
start to recognize as being a perfect
square well I have of course some
variable that is being squared which we
need I have some perfect square as the
constant and that whatever is being
squared there I have 2 times that as the
coefficient on this first degree term
here let's see if that is generally true
and I'll switch up the variables just to
show that we can so let's say that I
have a squared plus 14 a plus 49 so a
few interesting things are happening
here all right I have my variable
squared I have a perfect square constant
term that is 7 squared right over here
and my coefficient on my first degree
term here that is 2 times the thing
that's being squared that is 2 times 7
or you could say it's 7 plus 7 so you
can immediately say okay if I want to
factor this this is going to be a plus 7
squared and you can of course verify
that by multiplying out by figuring out
what 8 plus 7 squared
is sometimes when you're first learning
is okay isn't that just a squared plus 7
squared no remember this is the same
thing as a plus 7 times a plus 7 and you
can calculate this by using the foil fo
IL technique I don't like that so much
because you're not thinking
mathematically about what's happening
really yourself to do this tribute of
property twice here first you can
multiply a plus seven times a so a plus
seven times a and then multiply a plus
seven times seven so plus a plus seven
times seven and so this is going to be a
squared plus seven a plus now we
distribute this seven plus seven a plus
forty-nine so now you see where that 14
a came from its from the seven a plus
the seven a you see where the a squared
came from and you see where the 49 came
from and you can say speak of this in
more general terms if I wanted to if I
wanted to just take the expression A
plus B and square it that's just a plus
B times a plus B and we do exactly what
we did just here but here I'm just doing
in very general terms with a or B and
you can think of a is either a constant
number or even a variable and so this is
going to be if we distribute this it's
going to be a plus B times that a plus a
plus B times that B and so there's going
to be a squared now I'm just doing the
distributive property again a squared
plus a B plus a B plus B squared so it's
a squared plus two a B plus B B squared
so this is going to be the general form
so if a is the variable which is X or or
a in this case then it's just going to
be whatever squared in the constant term
is going to be two times that times the
variable and I want to show that there's
some variation that you can
your tain here so if you were to see 25
plus 10 X plus x squared and someone
wanted you said hey why don't you factor
that or you can say look this right here
is a perfect square it's 5 squared I
have the variable squared right over
here and then this coefficient on our
first degree term is 2 times 5 and so
you might immediately recognize this as
5 plus x squared now of course you could
just rewrite this polynomial as x
squared plus 10x plus 25 in which case
you might say okay variable squared some
number squared 5 squared 2 times that
number is the coefficient here so that's
going to be X plus 5 squared and that's
good because these two things are
absolutely equivalent